[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend an diesem 8 mai an dem sie
zwischen den meeren gewählt haben
nachher in der sendung fragen an den
wahlsieger den alten und neuen
ministerpräsidenten von
schleswig-holstein daniel günther von
der cdu es ist auch ein tag an dem sich
das ende eines fürchterlichen krieges
jährt und gleichzeitig ein neuer krieg
mitten in europa tobt heute vor 77
jahren 8 mai 1945
da lag dieses land in trümmern seine
menschen standen vor dem nichts vier
jahrzehnte hat es danach gedauert bis
ein bundespräsident diesem tag zum
ersten mal so beschrieb der
8 mai war ein tag der befreiung
er hat uns alle befreit von dem
menschenverachtenden system der
nationalsozialistischen
gewaltherrschaft
die räder hat damals streit ausgelöst
und diskussionen aber sie hat auch halt
gegeben und richtung wie kaum eine
andere eines bundespräsidenten davor
oder danach der bundeskanzler bezieht
sich heute auf diese weise gerede von
1985 olaf scholz wendet sich an die
deutschen an einem acht der so sagt er
für ihn sei wie kein anderer der ein
eigenes vermächtnis habe henriette de
maizière berichtet sie waren die sieger
und wurden die befreier die sowjetische
armee am 8 mai 1945 heute vor 77 jahren
endet in europa der zweite weltkrieg nun
gibt es wieder krieg in europa und so
wendet sich bundeskanzler olaf scholz
mit einer fernsehansprache an die
menschen darin betonte er sei geschichts
verfälschend und ant farm wie putin den
angriffskrieg mit dem kampf gegen den
nationalsozialismus gleichsetze in der
gegenwärtigen lage kann dies nur
bedeuten wir verteidigen recht und
freiheit an der seite der angegriffenen
wir unterstützen die ukraine im kampf
gegen den aggressiven
das nicht zu tun hier ist ihr zu
kapitulieren vor blanker gewalt und den
aggressor zu bestärken dieser achter mai
sei wie kein anderer
sg buchstäblich um krieg und frieden
aus vielen äußerungen die ich dieser
tage höhere spricht ernste sorge sorge
auch davor dass sich der krieg ausweitet
dass der frieden auch bei uns in gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt
angst darf uns nicht leben auf dem
bundeskongress des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes in berlin sagt
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
heute dieser krieg sei ein bruch mit
vielem was uns als
selbstverständlichkeit es sei
eingebrochen bruch
es sind gewaltige veränderungen vor
denen wir stehen absehbar noch sehr viel
tiefer und tiefgreifender als wir sie
heute diskutieren auch deshalb spreche
ich von einem epochenbruch die debatte
über den systemkonflikt zwischen
demokratien und autoritären regimen über
die zukunft der globalisierung und
unsere verantwortung in der welt
diese debatte steht mit höchster
dringlichkeit auf der tagesordnung
unsere demokratie müsse beschützt werden
nach innen und außen das zeige auf
brutale weise dieser krieg so steinmeier
und spricht von barbara in diese macht
ist der traum des gemeinsamen
europäischen hauses gescheitert ein
albtraum ist an seine stelle getreten
diese achte mai ein tag des krieges die
bilder des zerstörten berlin 1945 sie
ähneln den aktuellen bildern aus der
ukraine
der heutige achter mai er ist der 74 tag
des russischen angriffskrieges gegen die
ukraine
nie wieder
das ist die lehre aus dem schrecken der
weltkriege ein nie wieder das jetzt
gerade ankommen muss gegen die tägliche
flut von bildern und geschichten aus
einem neuen krieg in europa ein nie
wieder das ankommen muss gegen die kreml
propaganda und einen russischen
präsidenten der seinen landsleuten
weismachen will sein krieg gegen die
ukraine führe den kampf der roten armee
gegen die nazis vor 77 jahren quasi
weiter es gab heute viel gedenken in
deutschland es gab auch pro-russische
demonstrationen nicola albrecht
berlin treptower park heute mittag das
sowjetische ehrenmal ist das größte
denkmal für die gefallenen soldaten der
roten armee in deutschland was wir sehen
sind menschen die auch an diesem 8 bei
blumen niederlegen innehalten um die
opfer trauern und gleichzeitig an die
befreiung deutschlands vom
nationalsozialismus erinnern was die
bilder nicht zeigen dieser achte mai ist
anders wie kann man angesichts des
russischen angriffskrieges auf die
ukraine überhaupt angemessen gedenken es
herrscht verunsicherung
blickwinkel auf das gedenken ändern sich
besser herkommen um diesen kriegsende zu
bedenken angesichts des krieges in der
ukraine
und bin unendlich traurig dass
eigentlich nachdem wir so ein
schrecklicher krieg die menschheit schon
mal getroffen hat dass wir scheinbar
heute nicht weiter sind als auch wieder
mit waffengewalt irgendwelche probleme
zu lösen ich halte es trotzdem ein
bisschen auseinander auch wenn der krieg
schrecklich ist dass völker die hier
gemeinsam um die befreiung gekämpft
haben jetzt gegen krieg führen aber ich
finde es wichtig dass auseinander zu
halten und zu sagen nie wieder krieg nie
wieder faschismus dass frieden ganz
wichtig ist also dass es mir so bewusst
wie in keinem jahr zuvor viele
veranstaltungen in berlin und
brandenburg wurden abgesagt die
erwarteten pro russischen demos fanden
nur ganz vereinzelt statt topmodell ist
der direktor des historischen museums
karlshorst dem ort der kapitulation des
naziregimes er hat sein haus geöffnet
allerdings nicht im zeichen eines festes
wie in den jahren zuvor als historiker
weiß man um die bedeutung historischer
tage und schaut in die vergangenheit
aber ich merke dass eben ganz stark
nicht nur heute man kann die gegenwart
nicht ausblenden auch deswegen haben wir
ein format gewählt das jetzt deutlich
ruhiger und friedlicher ist dann kann
jeder mit sich selber ringen bereits
seit wochen wird über die sowjetischen
ehrenmal in berlin diskutiert manch ein
politiker forderte gar sie zu entfernen
mit blick auf den russischen aggressor
wirkten sie auf manche offenbar fehl am
platz obwohl sie an die befreier von
damals erinnern die nicht nur russen
waren
sowjetisches ehrenmal also es geht
letztendlich um 15 sowjetische
nachfolgestaaten das ist ja kein
russisches denkmal das ist unsere
fehlerhafte zuschreibung dass es hier
ein russländischen denkmal sei das
stimmt einfach nicht die polizei schützt
die veranstaltungen heute mit einem
großaufgebot ein flaggen verbot wird
verhängt sowohl für russen als auch
ukraine berlin will verhindern dass
geschichte politisch instrumentalisiert
wird und gleichzeitig
solidaritätsbekundungen mit der ukraine
zu lassen ein balance-akt in berlin in
potsdam programm der landtag in
brandenburg lädt ganz bewusst den
ukrainischen botschafter melnik zur
gedenkstunde ein in dessen rede erwähnt
er den aktuellen krieg nicht vielmehr
sieht der blinde flecken in den
geschichtsbüchern deutschlands man hat
in der bundesrepublik bis heute sehr oft
ausgeblendet last nicht russland sondern
die ukraine das hauptziel der eroberungs
politik und des nationalsozialistischen
deutschland im osten war und so wird
dieser 18
2022 nicht nur in berlin und brandenburg
zur herausforderung im kampf
negative er markiert eine zäsur in der
geschichte er schmerzt fordert antworten
mit dem blick auf vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft und einzig
wegschauen ist dabei keine option
dass dieser tag heute nicht nur
historische bedeutung hat sondern auch
ganz konkrete für die gegenwart und
vielleicht auch entscheidende für die
zukunft wird besonders in der ukraine
klar wo sie schon seit ein paar jahren
gemeinsam mit dem westen am 8 mai
gedenken und jetzt gleichzeitig mit
bangen auf den neunten mal schauen an
dem russland traditionell den tag des
sieges der roten armee über nazi
deutschland feiert selten ist die rede
die der russische präsident morgen auf
dem roten platz halten wird mit solcher
an spannung erwartet worden wird
wladimir putin versuchen einen sieg
gegen die ukraine zu verkünden oder
befiehlt er noch mehr krieg aus kiew
katrin eigendorf
es ist ein warmer frühlingstag in kiew
ein tag an dem man fast vergessen könnte
dass das land im krieg ist wären da
nicht die sirenen die panzersperren und
die warnung von neuen russischen
angriffen mit denen jeder jederzeit
rechnen muss auch bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas
staatsbesuch in schusssicherer weste der
gedenktag an die opfer des zweiten
weltkriegs wird an diesem 8 zur
historischen zäsur im mittelpunkt steht
jetzt das gedenken an die opfer des
russischen angriffskrieges und heute
sehen wir wieder was krieg anrichtet und
seien sie sich versichert ich bringe
nicht nur die solidarität des deutschen
volkes heute mit sondern natürlich auch
weiterhin die unterstützung sowohl
finanziell humanitär und das wissen sie
auch ein beschluss des deutschen
bundestages auch waffen zu liefern denn
das ist bedauerlicherweise immer noch
notwendig damit sie die freiheit und die
demokratie verteidigen in einer
videoansprache setzt präsident rollo die
mir selensky den ton für diesen achten
mai kein frühlingstag ein tag in schwarz
weiß
ihr sagt niemals wieder sagt es der
ukraine am 24 februar wurde das wort
niemals weggebombt durch hunderte von
bomben die die ganze ukraine um vier uhr
morgens auf weckten steuersenkung
zeit für gedenken hat sie lenski kaum
der druck die zukunft zu sichern
bestimmt auch diesen tag und das treffen
mit bärbel bas im präsidentenpalast
versöhnliche gesten vergessen die
diplomatischen verstimmungen
ich denke dass wir alle schwierigkeiten
überwinden werde die ukraine hat heute
gezeigt dass sie europa vereinen kann in
diesem sinne hat die ukraine in der welt
eine führungsrolle
risikobasierte sind die probleme gelöst
die verstimmungen beseitigt am dienstag
wird die deutsche außenministerin
annalena baerbock hier erwartet was sagt
ihr ukrainischer amtskollege
horst becker wir sprechen offen ehrlich
und direkt mit unseren partnern wir
schätzen was deutschland tun es ist wahr
deutschland kann mehr tun denn
deutschland ist die führende nation in
europa und wenn du ein führer bist sind
die erwartungen hoch expectations in
kiew ist es ruhig geblieben an diesem 8
doch die menschen blicken voller sorgen
auf morgen wenn russland den tag des
sieges feiert vielleicht auch mit
raketen auf die ukrainische hauptstadt
darf ich sie umarmen fragte der
ukrainische parlamentspräsident heute
seine deutsche amtskollegin
und tat es dann auch das ein zeichen
wir kommen nachher nochmal auf diesen
besonderen tag zurück der auch ein
wahltag war für die menschen in
schleswig-holstein nämlich und die haben
heute einen echten wahl sieger gekürt
mit riesigem abstand vor allen anderen
matthias guten namen nach kiel du
bringst du da werden die neuesten stand
dazu wie sehen denn die aktuellen zahlen
die aktuelle hochrechnung aus ja
christian weit mehr als 90 prozent der
stimmen sind jetzt ausgezählt wir sind
schon recht nah an einem endergebnis und
schauen auf die neuste hochrechnung
demnach bekommt die cdu hier in
schleswig-holstein
43,5 prozent der stimmen die spd 15,9
ihr schlechtestes ergebnis überhaupt
hier im land die grünen 18 18,3 das ist
ihr bestes ergebnis in schleswig
holstein die fdp 6,4
die afg 4,4 wäre damit nicht mehr an der
oder ist damit nicht mehr im landtag
vertreten
der ssw 5,8 andere insgesamt zusammen
5,7 darin auch die partei die linke mit
unter zwei prozent die wahlbeteiligung
übrigens ist auf knapp 60 prozent etwas
gesunken und wir schauen mal auf gewinne
und verluste und sehen hier in der
politischen landschaft in
schleswig-holstein jede menge bewegung
die cdu mit sehr klaren gewinnen die spd
mit fast genauso starken verlusten die
grünen gewinnen dazu die fdp verliert
die afg verliert weniger aber
entscheidend der ssw gewinnt auch dazu
und wir gucken noch oft die verteilung
der sitze im kieler landtag künftig das
werden 69 sitze sein das ist die regel
größe des landtags ist keine
überhangmandate keine ausgleichsmandaten
weil die grünen drei direktmandate
gewonnen haben die absolute mehrheit
liegt bei 35 die cdu kommt als 34 da
fehlt also nur ein sitz die spd 12 grüne
14 fdp 5 und ssw 4 soweit mal die zahlen
und die ausgangslage und matthias das
für eine mögliche regierungsbildung muss
das heißen breite auswahl oder
so ist dass wir schauen uns das mal an
hier sehen wir die linie absolute
mehrheit 35 die muss man mindestens
erreichen oder überschreiten cdu und
grüne 48 das reicht satt cdu und fdp 39
auch das noch recht deutlich das
dreierbündnis das derzeit regiert
jamaika natürlich erst recht das braucht
man politisch nicht wirklich war ins
neue bündnis erreicht cdu und spd
unwahrscheinliche konstruktion reicht
aber auch und das würde sogar reichen
für cdu und ssw 38 sitze zusammen die
absolute mehrheit bei 35 der ball liegt
also ganz klar im feld der cdu wir reden
gleich mit dem cdu-ministerpräsidenten
matthias vielen dank die bilder dieses
wahlabends im norden große gewinner also
historische verluste fast so hat audi
zusammen
bei der union und der gilt daniel
günther alter und wohl auch neue
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
die cdu mit abstand stärkste partei und
es reicht wohl auch für ein
zweierbündnis mit der fdp wenn auch nur
knapp
[Applaus]
also ist natürlich wirklich ein
enormer vertrauensbeweis
eine enorme unterstützung natürlich auch
für mich persönlich natürlich auch ein
wirklich hervorragendes ergebnis was
mich auch berührt auch persönlich wenn
man so eine unterstützung auch jetzt
bekommt stille
schockstarre dagegen bei den genossen
die zahlen schlimmer als befürchtet die
spd fährt in schleswig holstein ihr
bislang schlechtestes ergebnis ein
landet auf platz drei hinter den grünen
thomas lohse müller hat es schwer gegen
den beliebten günther zu pumpen und zwar
allen sehr klar dass das eine große
herausforderung ist in diesem wahlkampf
zu gehen gegen den beliebtesten
ministerpräsidenten der bundesrepublik
gegen eine landesregierung mit sehr
hohen zustimmungswerten
große freude zunächst auch bei den
grünen sie haben gewonnen und doch
irgendwie verloren trotz rekordergebnis
könnte es am ende die opposition werden
dabei wollen sie gerne weiterhin
mitregieren deshalb ist es aus unserer
sicht eine super gute bestätigung für
uns dass die menschen im land auch gerne
wieder wollen dass wir weiter mit
regierungsverantwortung tragen verhalten
aber zuversichtlich bernd buchholz und
die fdp die liberalen wieder im landtag
vertreten aber nicht zweistellig wie
angepeilt von enttäuschung dennoch keine
spur schwarz gelb hätte eine mehrheit
das ist das ergebnis auch es gibt die
möglichkeit in der mitte eine stabile
regierung mit uns zu bilden in diesem
land und das wollen wir auch und ich
sage mal das werden wir auch
zu den wahlgewinnern darf sich auch der
ssw zählen die partei der dänischen und
friesischen minderheit erzählt das beste
ergebnis der parteigeschichte
versteinerte mienen dagegen bei der afd
für sie wird der wahlabend zur
hängepartie sie könnte an der
fünf-prozent-hürde scheitern
schleswig holstein hat gewählt wer mit
wem ist nun die frage jetzt hat er die
wahl
ja und hier ist hier ist ja der alte und
wohl neue regierungschefin kiel daniel
günther guten alten tagen
herr günther ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ob
sie mich hören können das sieht
irgendwie nicht so aus doch
ich höre auf denn sie werde ja ich bin's
herr günther können sie mich hören das
ist fantastisch ja mein und alles gute
nach kiel toll dass das klappt sie haben
gesagt herr goethe sie seien 2017 er so
als notnagel ihrer partei
ministerpräsident geworden wenn sie
damals notnagel waren was sind sie jetzt
ja ich hab das damals als notnagel
bezeichnet weil wir ja eigentlich in
anderen spitzenkandidaten hatten und ich
bin ja dann sozusagen nur die vertretung
gewesen und habe glücklicherweise ja
dann die landtagswahl gewonnen und das
hat sich ausgezahlt denn offenkundig war
unsere arbeit gut in den letzten fünf
jahren als die jamaika koalition so dass
wir jetzt ein sehr gutes wahlergebnis
als cdu auch erreichen konnten mit 43
prozent das ist schon wirklich
sensationell gut und darüber freue ich
mich natürlich über diese entwicklung
jetzt haben sie die ganz große auswahl
an möglichen koalitionspartnern wir
haben gerade gezeigt bislang auch im
wahlkampf hatten sie sich immer taktisch
zurückgehalten und gesagt am liebsten
weiter so wie bisher heute abend sagen
sie überall ich werde jetzt mit beiden
reden also mit grünen und fdp wollen sie
am ende auch am liebsten beide wieder
haben
darüber werden wir natürlich sprechen
wie es weitergeht wer aber ich bin es
einfach konsequent ich habe vor der wahl
gesagt dass sie am liebsten in jamaika
arbeiten würde weil es einen hohen
zuspruch in der bevölkerung zu diesem
bündnis gibt mit grünen und fdp und
jetzt bleibt es auch dabei dass ich
natürlich mit diesen beiden parteien
auch gespräche führen werde wird sie
dazu einladen und was dann möglich ist
in welcher konstellation wir am besten
umsetzen können in den nächsten fünf
jahren auch die erfolgreiche arbeit
fortzusetzen und das weiter zu
entwickeln was wir begonnen haben das
werden die gespräche dann auch
entscheiden ja gut das ist ihr satz des
abends sehen sie überall wiederholen
aber mich würde jetzt interessieren
woran machen sie das denn konkret fest
also was ist der punkt wo sie sagen das
ist mir inhaltlich sehr wichtig der ist
für mich dann entscheidend am ende auf
welchem koalitionspartner ich die
einlassen werde
na ja für uns war das motto im wahlkampf
ja auch unser programm das wir sagen
kurs halten weil wir glauben dass wir
unser land schließlich deutschland die
die richtige richtung entwickelt haben
und von daher sind diese punkte auch für
mich ganz ganz wichtig dass sich das in
den verhandlungen durchsetzt dass wir
klimaziele in schleswig holstein
erreichen das land zwischen den meeren
haben wir ein riesen interesse daran
dass wir das schaffen aber wir wollen
das eben auch so schaffen energiewende
dass wir viele arbeitsplätze nach
schleswig-holstein holen dass viele
wirtschaftliche stärke auch in schleswig
holstein weiter entwickeln das bedeutet
dass wir weiter auch investieren können
infrastruktur dass wir für sozialen
ausgleich der diesen zeiten besonders
wichtig ist sorgen können und wir
glauben beim letzten mal hatten wir 32
jetzt haben wir über 42 prozent dass wir
vieles von den inhalten dann in einem
solchen bündnis auch und durchsetzen
könnten dann guckt man auch so ein
bisschen auf die bundespolitische
komponente wenn man so will in einer
woche sind ja auch wahlen in nordrhein
westfalen
herr günther sie waren in der
vergangenheit ich sag jetzt mal
vorsichtig dicht der allergrößte
friedrich merz fan ich zitiere sie mal
sie haben gesagt er zählt zu den älteren
männern die vielleicht nicht ihre
karriere ziele erreicht haben in ihrem
leben wie sieht es jetzt aus gibt es
jetzt ein neues team auch für die
bundesebene märz und günter
ja ich hab ja schon mal gesagt hat
friedrich merz und ich uns auch weiter
entwickelt haben in den vergangenen
monaten und wichtig ist jetzt bei dieser
wahl im badeland auswahl standen ja die
landesthemen im mittelpunkt aber
friedrich merz hat uns hier wahlkampf
unterstützt und es war auch in diesen
zeiten wichtig zu erleben dass wir eben
kein gegenwind aus berlin hatten man
musste ja befürchten dass die ampeln
strahlkraft entwickeln könnte die haben
sich schon nach fünf wochen denn nicht
mehr miteinander verstanden so dass das
ausgeblieben ist für die anderen
parteien dagegen hat uns die cdu hier
auch geholfen und deswegen bin ich auch
sehr zuversichtlich dass dieses signal
aus schleswig holstein jetzt auch
rückenwind für unsere parteifreunde in
nordrhein westfalen bringt und dass mein
freund hendrik wüst dort auch ein gutes
ergebnis holt direkt von einer cdu
wahlparty in kiel heute abend der alte
und neue regierungschef daniel günther
vielen dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne hätten wir
ja dann kommen wir jetzt noch mal aus
dem hohen norden zurück auf das große
bild der achte mai und die botschaften
die von ihm ausgehen zdf chefredakteur
peter frey kommentiert
mit seinem angriffskrieg zwingt putin
deutschland so einer klarstellung nach
seiner zeitenwende rede im bundestag
macht bundeskanzler scholz jetzt in der
zweiten fernsehansprache
in nur fünf monaten eine klare ansage an
unser land an seine partei und an das
westliche bündnis deutschland wird
keinen sonderweg mehr mit russland gehen
die botschaft ist schmerzhaft denn der 8
mai verbindet deutsche und russen für
immer als tag der erinnerung an den von
deutschen verursachten weltkrieg mit
seinen millionen opfern die meisten aus
der sowjetunion als tag der befreiung
auch durch die rote armee ohne die
deutschland den faschismus nicht
abgeschüttelt hätte deshalb schulden wir
den völkern der ehemaligen sowjetunion
etwas bis heute doch putins krieg ist
ein zivilisationsbruch er zerstört die
grundlagen die nach 1945 frieden in
europa garantierten dass putin seinen
krieg gegen die ukraine ihre
zivilbevölkerung und frei gewählte
regierung als befreiung vom faschismus
rechtfertigt ist eine groteske
verfälschung der geschichte eher betrübt
so auch sein volk das er durch
propaganda sind für die wahrheit macht
stolz macht mit seiner fernsehansprache
zum 8 mai klar dass wir uns gegen putin
rüsten und die ukraine verteidigen
müssen es ist nicht nur für die spd
tragisch und traurig dass nach
jahrzehnten friedlicher
partnerschaftlicher koexistenz mit
russland nun eine zeit klare abgrenzung
folgen muss am 74 kriegstag war die wahl
in schleswig holstein heute ein
politischer stimmungstest gstaad wurde
ein ministerpräsident der jetzt nur noch
einen koalitionspartner braucht grüne
oder fdp
das wird auch die macht balance der
ampel in berlin beeinflussen dass die
grünen die spd schlagen ist für die
kanzlerpartei eine demütigung nach einem
jahrzehnt des erfolgs fliegt die putin
freundliche afd erstmals aus einem
landtag so hatte dieser achte mai auch
aus kiel eine botschaft an moskau
der kommentar von peter frey und alle
weiteren wichtigen nachrichten an diesem
sonntag hast du jetzt im blick und da
geht es noch einmal um den krieg in der
ukraine
die g7 staaten haben weitere sanktionen
gegen russland beschlossen darunter auch
den ausstieg aus russischen öl importen
dieser soll schrittweise erfolgen heißt
es in einer gemeinsamen erklärung
die staats und regierungschefs der
führenden westlichen industrienationen
kamen heute zu einem virtuellen gipfel
zusammen an dem auch der ukrainische
präsident teilnahm
hongkong wird auch künftig ganz im sinne
der chinesischen zentralregierung
geführt ein gremium wählte john lee zum
neuen regierungschef er gilt als peking
treu und war unter anderem
sicherheitsminister hongkongs einen
gegenkandidaten hatte der 64 jährige
nicht wie spielte eine zentrale rolle
bei der niederschlagung der hongkonger
demokratiebewegung die 2009 10 millionen
demonstranten mobilisiert hatte
gegen den neuen csu generalsekretär
martin huber sind plagiatsvorwürfe
erhoben worden nun will dieser seine
doktorarbeit erneut von der
ludwig-maximilians-universität münchen
überprüfen lassen in der dissertation
hubers sollen laut einem plagiats
forscher zitate falsch oder nicht
ausreichend kenntlich gemacht worden
seien das berichtet die bild am sonntag
huber war erst vor zwei tagen zum
generalsekretär der csu gekürt worden
nachdem sein vorgänger stefan meyer
überraschend zurückgetreten war
mit einer spektakulären tor party haben
sich die fußballerinnen des vfl
wolfsburg ihren siebten deutschen
meistertitel gesichert bei absteiger fc
carl zeiss jena sorgten die wölfinnen
sehr schnell für klare verhältnisse
am ende stand ist zehn zu eins der
höchste saisonsieg und damit perfekte
abschluss am vorletzten spieltag feiert
wurde erstmal mit einer meisterschale
aus pappe die echte gibt's dann nächsten
sonntag
und wir bleiben bei der
fußball-bundesliga und wechseln zu den
männern da gab es heute drei begegnungen
eintracht frankfurt und borussia
mönchengladbach trennten sich eins zu
eins auch bei der partie bayern münchen
gegen den vfb stuttgart ein
unentschieden 2 2 und der rb leipzig
gewann gegen den fc augsburg 4 zu 0
wir gucken gleich noch live nach moskau
aber erst schnell in die kommende woche
birnleitner hat den heute journal
ausblick
[Musik]
am montag wird in berlin der
bundeskongress des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes jasmin fach chemie
zur vorsitzenden wählen die erste frau
an der spitze des dgb die 54 jährige spd
bundestagsabgeordnete war bis 2017
staatssekretärin im arbeitsministerium
sie folgt auf rainer hoffmann der seit
acht jahren dem dgb vorsitzt
am samstag werden die oberammergauer
passionsspiele premiere feiern corona
bedingt verschoben um zwei jahre
2100 einwohner des dorfes bringen das
spiel vom leben leiden und der
auferstehung jesu auf die bühne bis
anfang oktober wird das vorstellungen
geben ein großteil der tickets ist schon
verkauft
am sonntag wird in nordrhein westfalen
ein neues parlament gewählt ist eine
neuauflage von schwarz gelb unter
ministerpräsident muss reicht es laut
umfragen aktuell nicht die sehen die cdu
nur knapp vor der spd von herausforderer
kutschaty
und dann morgen wir haben schon darüber
berichtet der tag der großen parade und
der rede des russischen präsidenten in
moskau darauf werden morgen die augen
der welt liegen mit einiger anspannung
der britische verteidigungsminister etwa
warnt dass präsident putin eine
generalmobilmachung anordnen könnte
christiansens live heute abend in moskau
auf einer der achsen die zum roten platz
führen guten abend christian was es denn
von dem tag morgen heute schon zu spüren
tatsächlich ist der neunte mai noch
immer einer der wichtigsten feiertage
für die russinnen und russen wer kann
nimmt ein paar tage frei trifft sich mit
der familie ich habe das heute gesehen
es war ein schöner frühlingstag hier die
menschen gehen raus die menschen gehen
spazieren und das ist auch ein feiertag
wo man gerne die patriotischen symbole
zeigt ich habe das heute auch gesehen
man sieht das immer häufiger in diesen
tagen diese orange-schwarzen bändchen
die sieger bändchen die mittlerweile
aber er auch ein symbol sind um die
politik von wladimir putin zu
präsentieren ich habe zwei frauen
gesehen gibt es mit zwei großen russland
fahren durch den park gelaufen sind wo
hinten panzer drauf waren gleichzeitig
blicken die menschen aber auch
sorgenvoll auf den tag hier morgen was
sie schon angesprochen eine mögliche
mobil machen die macht auch vielen
menschen hier sorgen kommt wissen wir
nicht immer schwer vorauszusagen was
wladimir putin tatsächlich machen wird
wir haben im vorfeld hier bei den proben
auch gedreht hier auf der werster straße
die führt hier direkt auf den roten
platz wo morgen die panzer lang fahren
werden und ich würde sagen dieser tag
morgen hier ist auch für die russinnen
und russen morgen eine mischung aus
freude einerseits gedenken an den sieg
über nazideutschland und gespickt aber
auch mit sorgen was in der zukunft noch
so kommt
das zdf moskau herzlichen dank für diese
einschätzungen einordnungen und
erlebnisse heute
jetzt noch mal zurück nach deutschland
mit dem blick auf die wetteraussichten
morgen scheint die sonne bei oft
wolkenlosem himmel nur am alpenrand kann
es am nachmittag auch mal ein gewitter
geben die temperatur steigt auf werte
von 17 bis 26 grad auch in der nächsten
tagen bleibt es sommerlich allerdings
sind im norden mehr wolken unterwegs und
es kann schauer geben windig wird es
hier auch im süden kommen am donnerstag
gewitter auf
das war unsere welt an diesem sonntag
durch die kommende woche begleiten sie
ab morgen marietta slomka und heinz wolf
und die nächsten nachrichten gibt es
hier gegen 0.30 heute express mit mayer
weber vom gesamten team hinein einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]